here's the formula log base B of X
equals log base C of X over log base C
of B so what this means is you can pick
a new base base C okay and what you want
to remember is and it's easy to remember
that X goes in the numerator the B goes
in the denominator I always think the
B's a little bit lower so that's how you
can member goes in the denominator the X
is a little bit higher it goes in the
numerator I'll show you some examples
say for example you have log base 2 of
10 okay so we could write this as log
base 10 okay and then what we're gonna
do is we're gonna put the 10 in the
numerator we're gonna put the 2 in the
denominator we're gonna do log base 10
of 10 divided by log base 10 of 2 now
don't get confused this is not the same
thing as log base 10 of 5 you can't just
divide these and combine them into one
log you have to do these separately log
base 10 of 10 divided by log base 10 of
2 or another option is you could use
natural log so you could do natural log
of 1000 over natural log of 2 okay
these are all going to be equal to each
other it's just you're changing the base
I'll show you one more example let's say
you had log base 3 of 7 so what do we do
we do log base 10 of 7 over log base 10
of 3 7 goes in the numerator the 3 goes
in the denominator or or natural log of
7 over natural log of 3 exact same
answer it's just that some calculators
don't have the capacity to change the
base they just start restricted to
natural log the log base 10 so if you
have a calculator like this it's a quick
way to figure out approximately when you
do this on your calculator you can round
it to get an approximate answer of what
what this represents okay I'll see you
in the next video